images on the day that Israelis are
being slaughtered in their
beds what have you done about this the
problem is when we have people like
Barack Obama who lie about their
involvement they lie about the history
and all of those things you end up also
getting a set of people in government
who are not very good people one of
those not very good people is a Woman by
the name of Nea Ali and it turns out
that she is working at the Department of
Homeland Security and she is a radical
power Palestinian activist and you might
be concerned in light of what's
happening with the border and people
calling to destroy Israel and Destroy
America take over the west and the
chance for the Muslim armies in London
to take over that country you might not
want someone like this working in the
Department of Homeland Security so one
politician who's actually pretty decent
is Republican Josh Holly and there was a
hearing on uh this lady well there was a
hearing on the border largely and uh he
got into it with Alexander Alejandro
sorry ale and mayoras about this radical
Palestinian employee of the Department
of Homeland Security let let me ask you
about people who say other
things what about people who say things
like on October the 7th F Israel I'm
cleaning up the language here F Israel
the government and its military are you
ready for your
downfall people who say things like f
Israel and any Jew who supports Israel
may your conscience haunt your dreams
until tell your last breath Palestine
will be free one day F apartheid Israel
and is any Israel what this is pretty
extreme rhetoric don't you think Senator
um I do and I think there is a
distinction between espousing or
endorsing terrorist
ideology and uh Speech uh that is uh
odious that does not rise to that um
level fair enough this person works for
you this is nja Ali an employee of the
Department of Homeland Security who
posted these comments on October the 7th
that's not all she posted this is a
paraglider a Hamas
paraglider depicted here with a machine
gun flying into Israel she posted it
under her online
Alias with the celebratory free
Palestine Mr secretary what what's going
on here is this is this typical of of
people who work at DHS this is an asylum
and immigration officer who is posting
these frankly Pro genocidal
slogans and images on the day that
Israelis are being slaughtered in their
beds what have you done about this four
things I'd like to say to you number one
your question to suggest that that is
emblematic of the men and women of the
Department of Homeland Security is
Despicable I'm sorry what have you this
person works for the Department of
Homeland Security have you fired her
that was one of four answers have you
fired her I'm not even getting into the
other three how dare you ask me how dare
you besmer the good name of the people
of Department of Homeland Security just
because some lady who put up a poster of
a guy paragliding with a gun into Israel
after they it's just extraordin the
other extraordinary thing of course is
his eyebrows mayor' eyebrows I want to
do a whole can we do a documentary about
mayor' eyebrows we're go out on the road
I want to talk to eyebrow experts all
over the world find out what's going on
there okay it turns out that this woman
has been
promoted no just kidding uh she is she
is temporarily suspended so at least
they did something
there